i'm still mad now listen i'm not going  to sit down like all these clowns on  other networks got their head up the  lakers booties now they're blaming frank  vogel and russell westbrook  listen the people up top  who put that trash together are running  and hiding like cowards saying oh it's  frank it's russ you put all them old  geezers out there listen  the best guy other than lebron  in the last month has been who stanley  johnson yeah  and for y'all to be bringing a guy who  was on the street  and he becomes your second best player  and the general whoever running that  trash out there getting away uh  it's ridiculous man well what'd you  think about frank vogel last night you  know he was asked after the game  why wasn't russ playing in the fourth  quarter he said i put the guys out there  who i thought gave me the best chance to  win shaq and that's the coach's job  russ is not playing up to par i